20:16 just started but there's already a  brand new viral trend it's called CD  classes flipping do you know about it no  what you do we put them on like this and  then go oh yeah and then like that I got  this this is the thing I'm just making  that up we didn't do that we didn't do  that oh I got that I don't got it what  Wow flip your head back oh okay you did  so much and they open yes I see you  peekaboo see your love mixtape for me  maybe  think about this is a trend um I think  it's awful  alright well thanks for time we  appreciate it this is what I've been  waiting for all night this is the reason  why I came to the People's Choice Awards  so I could do this